and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a bomb tonight's review gravity
the greatest movie I've ever seen in my
life
houston we have spoilers dear sis woman
in space and she is joined by George
Clooney and Richard and they're out
there fixing pointless space thing for
then houston is like astronauts we have
a ton of debris hitting your way oh my
god is that gonna be a problem with all
our high-tech machinery down here don't
you think we'd be able to tell if it was
gonna be a problem oh my god that's a
problem oh butter don't need astronauts
are trying to dodge all the space debris
and astronaut Bullock is like it's okay
we still have time as long as I'm richer
guy is still alive now welcome after us
don't you worry I am George Clooney with
a rocket pack and I will fix everything
you see unrealistically calm and cool
through all this if you were George
Clooney with a rocket pack you would be
too well there's our astronaut Bullock
is kind of right and they are really
screwed I'm running out of oxygen don't
worry there's like a bajillion space
stations conveniently nearest one of
those convenient space stations have a
ton of fun convenient things about them
he'd be all right because I'm still
George Clooney with a record back don't
bump into one of the space stations and
I don't mean come across I need bump
I need Lee to call this bumping the
movie but then acinar Clooney's about to
be bumped into space but Bullock's him
no you have to because that lasagna
holding you to the spaceship won't let
me ever see you again
if convenient symbolic writing would let
me who's directing this picture anyway
the guy you do all the Harry Potter's
I'll definitely be back the astronaut
Bullock is like to get inside this thing
and figure out how to get room but first
I must take part in a rebirth metaphor
that was fun so unfortunately the
spacestation she's on is on fire I was
on fire once never juggle torches with
Courtney Love but she figures out it's
okay because there's another Space
Station over there hurry
breathe out gasps this sucks I see
crimes inside the space station and he's
like I hear the radio signals of an
Asian man talking to his dogs and baby
back on earth the guy is like why did my
baby's first words sound like a
screaming astronaut in space so I stir
that bullet - sighs maybe today is a
good day to die there's no point in
calling for help anymore I'll just let
death take me one more time mama I think
baby either needs doctor or therapist
but then it's a ghostly apparition of
George Clooney appears no Billy that
happens and goes Clooney is like cool
I'm ghost Clooney have you come to give
me hope in my desperate time of need
who's the backup Oh what oh yeah go on
living your good kid Oh George Clooney
mmm-hmm how can we submit that your
spiritual apparition and that's just a
figment of my imagination not you being
open to interpretation but instead
clarifying that another world exists
this button get you home so astronaut
Bullock pushes the button to get her
back home but this ship starts burning
apart falls in the water and is on fire
again well night yeah why does the
universe hate Sandra Bullock okay then
Miss Congeniality movies were pretty bad
but she may not with it with the heat oh
and speaking of heat fire said your boy
oh so she swims out of the ship reaches
the surface and crawls onto land so
gravity was really intense in a really
great movie and it's definitely teach me
a very valuable lesson never door the
space is mysterious place in the world
there's nothing but stations that don't
work and poorly we have Star Trek
sequels I'd be safer sleeping in a snake
pit which by the way lets you take free
souvenirs isn't that returnees it's just
a bump ow take your other eye
nobody wanna help but I do have a
one-eyed snake trying to kill me